les chants qui sont pas là en face de
vous le peut-être à la télévision c'est
pas la même chose qui passe mais vous
êtes
l'aspect physique très sexy très très
comme ça se fait au premier degré et
franche sartoux et moi je depuis que je
vous vois là depuis le début de
l'émission et même avant quand on se
maquille et où je sens exactement le
contraire chez vous c'est à dire quelque
chose de complètement pas désespérer
mais
romantique enfin complètement discret
timide et ou alors je vous faisais juste
une question dans les l'amour ou les
amours vous a vécu dans votre vie qu'est
ce qui vous a le plus touché quelque
chose de
je veux pas vous faire acquis que je
sers d'amour mais bon là vous avais les
larmes aux yeux c'est pas du bidon je
sais pas si on le voit à la caméra
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous
montreront jacques en quoi est ce que ma
touche est ce que vous avez dû au début
a toujours écouté derrière un côté pile
que les gens perçoivent pas toujours